welcome to this video and playing town
tavern town 7 no no name I think at one
point he had a header British flag UK if
like okay we have a arm Vienna game not
to the most ambitious of openings for a
white but definitely definitely very
solid t4 with the loss of a temple 97 or
yeah maybe 97 I could have taken it's
not probably not bad what took aim this
this looks like it's a bit like a funny
door structure but with the bishop
active so taking with the pawn or with
the night but the night would lead to
some exchanges well it looks looks quite
comfortable for me okay I'm stop taking
oh wait if if I do that okay but I have
to play against your phone book eh
I was a dollar opening my word I know
it's a game of two persons sign can also
blame me but I really didn't do anything
here before now what what are you doing
doing about this we can take you can
take on d6 and trade the board down ok
now is trying to do something night c4
may be coming I but ok I can I can play
this amongst others preparing t5 let's
see for I can just take and play Knight
takes e4 at the end ok so would be five
yes you 5v5 does not look like any
problem f4 yeah but I have Bishop f5
this is just one night 97 even at night
f5 yeah why not
yeah Bishop f5 I guess to get rid of the
bishops see playing night h4 in the near
future maybe night h4 I can take play 96
I guess okay okay get this to g6 cover
each form I didn't think about that that
that was that was a mistake I mean from
my side should have thought about this
move a bit mmm a stupid
this wasn't intended maybe it's still
okay Knight takes Knight eggs I have
this 93 idea
before I've designed to prevent them c5
and now 9 f 54 smile was my intention
with this traits I managed to get it the
porn on d3 not the Queen so that I could
maintain the blockade on f5
yeah d3 is probably really attacked not
afore probably not so what to continue I
can just try to grab the AL Rookie three
I would like to get the knight to e 69 f
86 but he always has night h form ok
trying to give this up look III I can
always get the Bishop to e3 can build
both pieces and protect it but I didn't
see a way for him to exploit it
maybe just deform
I think you can just play d4 I don't
really know what to do against this
don't see a very good news now my pieces
are both are protected 23 or something
and we'll take a player 5 I guess
at night is seven I am ok d for hangs
are found hang so maybe cannot do that
I'm sure about the Queen move this was a
very great height whining this cheeky I
want Knight to f5 if possible oops
what's this more night night coming to a
fiver ok I also must take this anyway
Queen seat
check night maybe just cover it back
rowing meet
looks even backroom it no I what the
heck I know this is this is really
annoying you got totally outplayed in
this game ah black resigns Brooke f3 yes
yeah it's not even working i got rookie
three that just I this is annoying I
mean no this is was totally one-sided
game this is this is totally not working
I mean apparently not probably I didn't
even reviewed it the best queen bee five
is better okay this seems this is good
for white actually with 97 so queen bee
fire was right but here i am- fire here
now little time but still and here look
83 is just winning and something like
that I'm to I'm two pawns up for nothing
yeah the way I'm saying what got out
plate because this is just a very bad
structure I have to throw better pawn
structure here pawns on light squares
got a bad bishop on g3 I have a light
squared locate and this is all week I
all only was a bit worried about those
two pieces they are unprotected and this
is always tricky in blitz of course but
it's just better for black it's just a
matter of how much better is it like a
clearly better slightly better compass
on 0.5 so nothing dramatic but it got
got much worse later
when when white was just lost two sixes
it's not a very good move but of course
white is passive so it's not so easy to
play here with with little time and time
check yeah i don't know i'm really not
good with the little time on the clock
at the moment i was i was better at this
earlier yeah this is just idiotic Queen
a3 it's not even difficult yeah okay
thanks for watching